la pluie n'a pas dérangé les
participants du 42e paris-versailles de
l'histoire cette année encore 25000
courageux se sont élancés ce dimanche 29
septembre depuis la tour eiffel pour
rejoindre la cité royale
au programme 16 km c'est mythique
c'est une des courses une des quatre
cinq courses mythiques en france puis
aux mets vins du coin d'ailleurs on
court en pleine campagne mais c'est pas
un trade c'est difficile mais à
l'arrivée on est toujours satisfait et
l'organisation l'ambiance si certains
sont venus pour le plaisir d'autres sont
venus pour la performance le champion de
france du semi-marathon julien 2 vannes
faisait partie de cette deuxième
catégorie
ils l'emportent au bout de l'effort en
52 minutes avec une minute et 12
secondes d'avancé sur faustin guignand
je suis parti tout seul en tête
j'adore courir comme ça j'aime partir à
fond et c'est resté à fond vous savez il
y avait cette route
les gardes qui est une des principales
attractions de cette course et
j'arrivais tout seul au pied et j'ai
essayé de maintenir mon avance pour pour
essayer de lever les bras à versailles
chez les féminines laurie lindekens
deuxième l'an passé franchi cette fois
ci la ligne en première position la
sportive en portant une heure une minute
et trente cinq secondes
d'ailleurs j'ai fait 2e la première et
surtout j'améliore vendre c'est surtout
ça l'essentiel longue à la presse
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
43e édition les organisateurs espèrent
le retour du soleil en 2020